Thank you for sharing your responses on the forum. Now,
in writing all of this code, we've seen a lot of
new words. Let's review all of them. So here I
have both of my programming files on the screen at the
same time. Here's my first programming file where I'm making
the class movie. And the second one, when I'm defining instances
of that class, instances like Toy Story and Avatar. Now, you
may have to go into Full Screen mode to be able
to read all of the details on the screen.
Okay, let's start reviewing all of the new words.
So, we started out by defining a class. The
class Keyword allows us to make classes. You can think
of a class as a blueprint. And a class
can have both data and methods. Now, we can
create multiple instances of a class. In this case,
we created instances like Toy Story and Avatar. We could
have created many more. Now, when we create
an instance of a class, instance like Toy
Story, the classes constructor gets called. This is
essentially the init method inside the class. It is
here that we initialize all of the data
associated with the instance. The constructor uses the keyword,
self. Now, you can think of self as
itself or the instance in question. So, when the
instance Toy Story is getting created, self is
Toy Story. All the variables associated with a specific
instance are called instance variables. Now, these are
unique to an object and can be accessed using
the self keyword inside the class and the
instance name outside the class. And, finally, all of
the functions inside the class that are associated
with an instance and have the first argument as
self are called instance methods. So there you have it. All of the
new words that we have learned thus far, right there on one screen.